uh Britain now has its third prime
minister in two months at Rishi sunak's
appointment was formalized at an
audience with head of state King Charles
at Buckingham Palace the former Finance
Minister gained the support of the
ruling conservative party after his main
Rivals stepped aside at 42 years old
he'll be Britain's youngest head of
government for more than 400 years he
takes over from Liz truss who beat him
to the job seven weeks ago and was then
forced to resign after upsetting
financial markets with her economic plan
after his audience with the King Mr
sunac headed to his new residence at 10
Downing Street where he addressed the
country as prime minister for the first
time
I will place economic stability and
confidence
at the heart of this government's agenda
this will mean difficult decisions to
come the government I lead
will not leave the Next Generation
your children and grandchildren
with a debt to settle that we were too
weak to pay ourselves
I will unite our country
not with words
but with action
well DW correspondent to Burgett mass is
now outside the 10 Downing Street uh
welcome burget
um Talk us through the highlights of
this speech
well I thought it was quite striking
that he actually started by almost
criticizing uh his predecessorless trust
he said he was he's coming in in order
to fix the problems that were created uh
by the previous government so that was
quite striking he then uh was also a
little bit conciliatory and said that he
obviously also supported her government
and also thanked Boris Johnson for for
the majority that he has achieved in
2019 for their conservative party so you
know quite a little quite a lot of Party
politics are there to start with and
then it's really about his program so he
needs to spell out a little bit in more
detail
um what exactly he wants to achieve as
prime minister but I think he's given a
taster so he was emphasizing that he
does not want the generations to come
with the debts and that they have so
that this generation and basically here
and now the debts need to be settled so
that probably means budget cuts or tax
Rises it's going to be very difficult
for him he's somebody who is incredibly
wealthy himself together with his wife
they are thought to be a wealthy of
hundreds or millions of pounds but he
will be the one to tell the British
people that they basically have to have
to live with with cuts that's at least
is expected and he has given a taster of
of what what there might be to come yes
a cost of living a crisis which we're
all facing one of his suppressing issues
what else is at the top of his list
will feel the cost of living crisis
obviously that's the backdrop that he
was elected into so many British people
have uh problems there are pensioners
who are not daring to ball themselves a
cup of tea just because they think it's
going to eat into their electricity
budget and families who don't know how
to feed their children how to put warm
food on the table for their children or
people afraid to heat their homes so
there is a really a lot of hardship
already in the UK and Rishi Suna will
have to strike a balance he will have to
help those people who are most in need
but on the other hand he also is saying
that he does want to balance the book so
he doesn't want to continue to increase
the debt so he needs to really uh flesh
out how exactly that's going to work is
he going to ask the better off in
society to pay more or is he going to be
uh very very drastic and are there going
to be a lot of cuts and public services
he's says he wants to he wants to
bolster the Health Service and also
education so he has said what he wants
to achieve but how is that going to work
if he also needs to look really for for
cuts in government budgets thank you for
that burger to Burgett mass in London